[Applaudissements]
que la prod de secret story avait
insisté auprès de vous pour vous marier
avec senna dans la maison a déjà proposé
un deal assez fou et vous aviez demandé
à voir de l'eau chaude illimité non mais
en fait à l'époque quand on m'avait dit
pour le mariage
une fois qu'ils avaient pu de prêt mais
que cgt au confessionnal et jeudi mais
je ne marie pas puisqu'il avait déjà
lancé toute la procédure a non mais je
le dis dans le livre nous et vous avez
été obligé de vous mari non mais c'est
pas obligé parce que aller pour fait
quand on est enfermé depuis trois mois
tu sais plus ce que tu dis tu sais plus
ce que tu fais en fait tout simplement
c'est comme eux et du cou du coup voilà
et puis après ils ont dit que tu veux
quoi et moi j'ai dit bellevue l'eau
chaude et du coup mais voilà c'est ça
ouais quand vous êtes mariés contre de
l'eau chaude et autres chouettes steve
ott